So let's look at the solution to our
multicore versus single core quiz.
This is what we had in
the old technology.
In the new technology, one of these
cores is going to be half the size and
half the power.
So we have the option of either
replacing that with a better core that
occupies the whole area, get us more
IPC, but consumes slightly more power.
And then the question is, if we do
consume the whole power budget of
the chip, which is a hundred watts,
how much can we increase this frequency.
And with that frequency,
what is the overall speed up versus
what we had in the old technology?
The other options was just, put the two
cores that we can now fit on the chip.
Each now gets us the same
IPC as the single core did.
And together,
they consume the whole power budget
of the chip at two gigahertz.
So the question is,
what's the speed up versus the old
technology with the two core approach?
The first thing we need to figure out
here is how much can we raise this
frequency here so
that we get to 100 watts.
Well, we're allowed to increase
the power from 75 watts to 100 watts.
That's a factor of 1.33.
And remember that the dynamic power is
proportional to voltage squared times
the frequency itself.
And that we have to increase
the voltage in proportion to frequency.
So if we are spending power
to increase the frequency,
we have to proportionally get both
the voltage and the frequency up.
And that means that we
will be spending power
in proportion to the cube
of the frequency.
That means that the frequency that
we can operate on is cubic root of
1.33 times the old frequency,
and this is equal to 1.1.
So our new frequency is 1.1
times the old frequency.
The old frequency was 2 gigahertz.
That means we can achieve 2.2 gigahertz
when we increase the power by
a factor of 1.33.
The speed up we achieve versus the old
technology will be the speed up we
achieve because of a shorter clock cycle
time, and that speed up is 1.1 times.
So we are 1.1 times faster now,
in terms of clock frequence,
times the speed up we achieve
because our IPC's better.
And if we divide 3.5 and 2.5, we get
a factor of 1.4 times the speed up which
is because we have fewer instructions.
But because we are executing exactly
the same code, that speed up is one.
We don't speed up, really.
So our overall speed up is just this.
And it ends up being 1.54.
Now, let us look at the two core option.
We have the same IPC as before.
But we now have two cores
that are doing that.
So we are executing twice as
many instructions as before,
at the same frequency and
at the same power.
So the speed up versus the old
system here will simply be two.
We are operating at the same frequency,
splitting the same work into two pieces,
and each of the pieces is now
done at the speed where we were
doing only one of the pieces.
So overall we are getting
a speed up of two.
As you can see, two cores are achieving
a better speed up relative to the old
system, than a fancier core.
Which means that if we indeed do have
programs that can use the two cored
effectively, then this is the better
option than improving the core and
consuming the cheap area that way.